hello there reject nation I'm very
comfortable I'm Craig Alva this is Casey
Spivey Casey Spivey has returned to the
real rejects channel you should go check
out her YouTube channel youtube.com
slash blonde jokes the series yes on
Instagram it's the blonde some hilarious
sketches if you want to look at
good-looking girls being funny which
people think is impossible especially
this guy but they pulled it off
you saw Joker right uh yeah but you in a
great mood didn't it yeah I was crying
for three hours though Fame Wow and the
movie is only two hours there's this
WatchMojo video that got sent to us that
I was like this sounds like an
interesting debate it's called best
Joker Heath Ledger versus Joaquin
Phoenix now I have some opinions as I'm
sure you have opinions too yeah we will
reveal set opinions once reaction is
over and discuss based off whatever you
know what I'm wasting too much time
let's just watch this two incredible
actors one roll welcome to watchmojo.com
is a late great Heath Ledger against the
living legend Joaquin Phoenix to see who
gave us the superior excreting will sing
how long as we evaluate a wide range of
categories to determine which
interpretation of the Clown Prince of
Crime reigns supreme makeup this is okay
all right the first are a lot of
contributing factors that go into making
pop culture figure there's no denying
that its trademark look ranks pretty
highly on that list
sure for his 2018 take on the character
director Todd Phillips borrows some
elements directly from the comics while
also taking a few notable liberties
Phoenix Sports Joker's trademark purple
suit complete with the orange yellow
vest and blue green accents it's perfect
for Joker's face however the clown
makeup is a pretty major departure from
the source material going for a more
classic glam look including blue
triangles around the eyes and a red nose
when you bring me out can you introduce
me as ecology director Christopher Nolan
arguably took even greater liberties
with Joker's aesthetic purple is still
the characters go-to color but the coat
is longer more of a purple overcoat than
a traditional suit jacket or tail coat
in the comics the Joker's face is
permanently white but Ledger's version
of the character is clearly wearing
makeup which visibly smudges throughout
the film I'd love to have some most
minimal however is the addition of
Glasgow smile stars which he accentuates
with red makeup to create his twisted
smile stick to the blade in my mouth
Thanks
neither of these takes on the joker's
aesthetic feels quite as comic accurate
as Jack Nicholson's and that's okay
he's going to make so Jack Nicholson's
the winners overcoat but when it comes
to deviations from the source material
legends seem more effective the scars in
particular feeling like a better choice
when Phoenix is traditional clown makeup
Leger takes round one winner Leger round
two laughs comics might be a soundless
medium but even on the page laughs feels
distinct a key part of his perverse
identity now it's safe to say that
Joaquin Phoenix has clearly put his own
spin on the Joker's laughter it's an
open-mouthed full-body lash one that
seemingly comes out of nowhere going
from 0 to 100 and sometimes stopping as
if I would give Joaquin Phoenix this how
integral it is to start off low it often
rises to become quite high-pitched which
is when it's most unnerving what Arthur
is particularly uncomfortable however
it's high-pitched right from the get-go
and that's arguably the most interesting
aspect of this interpretation of the
laughs it's actually a nervous tic that
predates Arthur's Joker identity
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's most intriguing about his
particular take on it is that the
character seems so self-aware of his
laughter he twists the laughs and
changes it depending on the situation
sometimes it's low and ominous other
times it's a high-pitched rasp when he
wants into the crime boss meeting to
perform his pencil trick a glass which
is something the Joker isn't
particularly known for that's what makes
Ledger's last so distinct just a madman
who loves the fact he's a madman who
wields his laugh like a weapon a tool to
scare and unnerve others when most
people imagine the Joker's laugh it's
Mark Hamill's animated iteration that
comes to mind so Mark Hamill
both Phoenix and Ledger's laughs are a
major departure from this and each
manages to accomplish something totally
unique with it true by giving the lamp
of psychological foundation and helping
the creepy factor Phoenix takes the
round yeah whenever Phoenix
[Music]
it is like the portrait of Kaiser
honestly just right from your name and
your aesthetic to your particular
criminal scheme yes even more so than
most super villains is known for his
elaborate larger-than-life and
needlessly convoluted flaws now we don't
I mean what your has Phoenix's Joker is
more of a force of nature and symbol
than an elaborate steamer yeah Joker
criminal mastermind in the comic books
is not this good for cartoonish ploys
well
Phoenix ain't playing that kind of clown
[Music]
Heath Ledger's take on a character with
okay you're not in your head wasn't
interested in clown themed plots smiley
faces or poison laughing gasps but for
all the colorful theatrics Nolan
stripped away from the character his
preference for cool games nonetheless
felt very true to the character do I
really look like a guy with a plan you
know what I am chasing cars how would I
know what to do with what if I caught
you know I just do things throughout the
film very experiment to his double
kidnapping of Rachel and dent his deadly
shenanigans like the opening bank
robbery oh yeah exactly the sort of
planning we expect from the Clown Prince
of Crime make up a side
neither ledger improv show curse yeah
characters more carnivalesque side but
between the two Ledger's Joker
definitely showcases a greater aptitude
for comic-book were these schemes where
as Phoenix's Joker is on more of a
personal privilege Ernie winner ledger
round four psychology and motivations as
Arthur Fleck angeleka Joker yeah you
kind of just hear the category guiding
him on a path of violence and willful
chaos of course he's also some specific
bones to pick eunuchs fully inhabits
this role and why dialing the crazy up
to eleven delivers an awe-inspiring
performance making this character no
matter how sick feel fully fleshed out
my mother always tells me
- smile and put on a happy face Alfred
said it best triggers every time just
wanna watch it well done
Heath Ledger's Joker liked his comic
book counterpart is wholly disinterested
in material goods for wealth he is an
agent of chaos
pure and simple to him order is a
construct or rather an illusion and he
wants to prove that the world is in fact
every bit as crazy and unpredictable as
he is you remind me of my father my
father in many ways he sees himself as
the hero an emissary for a harsh and
nihilistic truth in a society obsessed
with imposing order the thing is though
he can be erratic he's also quite lucid
which is just what makes his motivation
so terrifying Heath Ledger undeniably
took the Joker to unprecedented
cinematic Heights by really making his
psychology one that we wanted to dissect
and analyze but Batman remains the
central figure
whereas 2019 s Joker is a character
study dedicated to Arthur's twisted mind
which Phoenix does a masterful job
bringing to life we continue be sure to
subscribe to our Channel
and bring the Bell category who has more
screen time wow you are really guiding
us boys I mean whose attorney he doesn't
really change this for us we argue that
it's redundant to compare voices
considering the Joker's voice and laugh
are two very different beasts each doing
a voice but no one has ever gone in
quite such a unique direction as Phoenix
you know listen I mean he's doing it for
size please do here's much more
range he's doing a cadence in town
somehow scarier than the typical villain
[Music]
[Laughter]
playing the role Heath Ledger is
constantly manipulating his voice much
like every aspect of his character
regardless of his tone inflection volume
mantra maintains a maniacal edge one
that makes you hang on to every word you
see in there this was a tough one as
compelling unique and unnerving as
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker voice was it
doesn't always feel like Joker Ledger by
contrast went with a voice that well
definitely different from Joker's past
felt while expressive and dynamic three
words that epitomize the character and
so he takes the final round competition
winner pleasure thank you that's it
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker officially sucks
now guys I've decided either or you
can't have both
and you can't appreciate the difference
I made I'm ty no that would have been a
cop-out well I kind of loved your muster
right now I'm just probably out-of-focus
WatchMojo
kind of our freshman robot I've never
really wanted to be in the position to
compare these two jokers yeah cuz
they're so different one feels like they
are really borrowing from the comics and
another one feels like a character study
where they kind of had the backdrop of
Joker to it walking Phoenix one could
have been any could have been a number
things normal person just swap out like
Joker swap out Thomas Wade and you kind
of have its own thing you know so it's
like comparing apples and oranges apples
and orange orange they're so different
they both have such different effects I
think in terms of representing Joker
from the comics I would absolutely like
easily give it to to heat the ledger
because of the body language the
mannerisms the fact that it's a criminal
mastermind psychotic and funny there's a
whole different layer of appreciation
for if we're talking to cinema walking
Phoenix
totally gives the emotional tour de
force performance you know what I mean
that's not to minimize he's still my
personal favorite Joker but it's weird
to compare the Joker's yeah I mean you
know well they're acting with completely
different goals in mind and he's he's
the villain of the story in Joaquin's
he's the hero of the story yeah so
they're Kapil's and oranges it's like I
loved Joaquin so much but it's also a
completely different movie it's the
Joker as the major Duren hero and it was
like devastating to see through that
lens but in the traditional comics he is
the villain so you're right about it
yeah hitting the same note with Heath as
originally intended The Killing Joke
which is known to be the main origin
source of Joker
there are things in Joaquin's Joker
portrayal that are definitely at the
stand of comedy background experience
and such but that's really about it
The Killing Joke he has like a life yeah
kid on the way he's got all these other
things going on and he's getting
involved with criminals there are some
things that remind me of The Killing
Joke if you're just talking comics
accuracy if you're tough like one Joe
they pretty much said of here Joker in
in Batman's is criminal mastermind and
Joaquin's it's just dude with a major
mental illness who's wronged by society
and goes on a total psychopathic journey
right but there's nothing about him that
really feels like he evolves into
criminal Matthew evolves in a cult
I mean spoilers if I was in the cult
leader but he doesn't involve it - like
the dude who I could see taking on
Batman I could see him taking on little
Bruce Wayne do you think that this movie
would have been the same if they had had
Heath be the hero of the story back in
the day I kind of think that based on
what we've gone through as a culture
recently this was so potent political in
a way that I don't think that we would
have been as sensitive to ten years ago
and it was definitely like a a message
about maybe how some people who come off
as evil get that way and how many people
failed them along the way it was a very
strong take on that in some ways it's
like a PSA for mental illness awareness
and also a lot of ways of how we do go
about treating people when I saw the
movie there are these three dudes behind
us who just totally reminded everyone I
was with of the three dudes in the movie
on the subway who were just laughing
hysterically at super depressing moments
of a dude accurately portraying these
really harsh things he's going there are
things that are not funny but they're
like laughing I hear them coming like
what a freaking weirdo what a freak the
thing that made me cry throughout it is
that I think there's some people who
have never had an experience like that
who have never not had healthcare and
yeah broken their foot and couldn't go
see a doctor not speaking from
experience like you know what I mean or
been super behind on their water bill
and it just keeps dragging you down and
down and down and down like there are so
many people who have lived that reality
that know what it's like to have
something that you really need taken
away because it's not funded anymore
or whatever there's people who will
never have that experience and don't
realize that that is a real thing that
happens it's hard like when you're at
the bottom you just keep getting punched
it's just like you know that's what made
me cry throughout the whole thing is
I've never seen a movie really nail that
on the head to add to that point and
with this video it's it's hotter when is
that Joaquin's is relatable
you know Heath Ledger's is so
fascinating yeah wildly entertaining and
like hmm undeniably gripping yeah but I
don't relate with figure I like he might
make a few points here like that's got
him an interesting point there's nothing
about him per se where I'm like I told
her I connect with this guy
ya know he's still at a distance he's
still the villain yeah whereas Joaquin
is portrayal
I think there's what makes the character
such a powerful portrait is that even
without the healthcare stuff there's
there's so many layers to that
performance if there's something that
most of us can identify yeah that should
have been one of the category hey yeah
Dark Knight is one of my favorite movies
I think overall I liked that movie more
overall but the performance of walking
gripped me in a way that the Joker in
that movie your origin yeah exactly it's
one thing to compare the Pennywise from
the miniseries in the it movie because
one's a remake
they're both adapting the same thing
uh-huh this is not that completely yeah
like they're so Drac like the whole
thing with the voice that was an
interesting thing to bring up because I
think when a Joker is cast that things
are they're versing on I think actually
makes sense because those are the things
that we tend to go okay what's he gonna
look like what's his voice gonna be
what's his laughs gonna be absolutely
give it to the laughs because I was so
Integris with Joaquin character but the
but the voice I I thought it was gonna
be
each transformed he likes he has a
switch it's a totally different person
but even when he's on the talk show he's
like he's still talking in his regular
voice so I won't even call it a Joker
voice well I could see Joaquin's
character
evolving into Heath's character Fletcher
it very easily sure sure so Apple store
origins all right
which one was your favorite Joker which
one would you pick we're at war with
each other now yeah subscribe to
watchmojo.com blonde jokes watching
girls be funny it's a rarity Hey and
that's the point of the channel I'm just
trying to provoke you if you don't
subscribe she won't come back oh did you
go check out her channel subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell before wrap this up I do a page of
the day shout out to a man named Tyler
hey Tyler Casey I don't think I've told
you about this guy he lives in Wisconsin
and he actually for my birthday he got
me last year a ps4 Pro what yeah yeah
and what I did was I showed footage of
him embarrassing himself at a stand-up
comedy performance oh great and Wow
fitting yes so awful at comedy but I
invited him on here and planning on
doing an interview with him we're gonna
livestream it so it's gonna be an
exciting time this is so like the Joker
what no he's gonna it's gonna be great I
don't think that's necessary Tyler's
gonna be very happy just to be
recognized here on a public live format
and maybe we'll crack some jokes at him
nobody's super fun I bet he'll be great
patron shout out a complete